Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you can call and leave me a voicemail.
That number is 2192.
David P. Here is a caller.
Furious that I'm not talking about alien spaceships.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hey, Dave.
Steve in San Diego.
Yes, sir.
Your vexing cosmic conscience calling in once
again to challenge you on your utter failure
to address the most important story in the
history of the planet, which is UFOs are real.
We have not totally accredited all the justification
and backing in the world type guy who has
just come out, an official whistle blower
saying, Look, this is real.
You have to deal with it.
Stop playing games.
Okay.
You might some you might find are playing
games still.
You ignore the story.
You don't want to cover it.
You've minimized it.
You've dismissed it.
Instead, let's go yet another segment on why
Donald Trump is bad and how you can look all
superior and smarmy pointing that out.
Whether or not Donald Trump is bad is not
the point.
Point is, you would rather cover nonsense
than the most important story ever.
And the answer must be you're afraid.
You're afraid.
Dave, I'm calling you out.
Why?
Because if UFOs are real and they are, they
called into question.
It undermines everything that you're touting
as being so important to cover.
Speaker 1: That is quite a conspiracy theory.
Now, I think it's really important to mention
when you say UFOs are real.
All you're saying is there have been flying
objects that were unidentified.
What this caller means and what this caller
is referring to is that intelligent aliens
with spaceships are real.
I've acknowledged UFOs are real in the sense
that there have been flying objects that we
did not at least immediately identify.
That is very different than what is now being
said now.
What is this individual referring to?
Two days ago, two alleged whistleblowers have
come forward and have said the US has in its
possession intact alien vehicles.
They are not from China or Russia.
We know that these are from aliens, from other
planets.
We have intact vehicles and it is being covered
up.
Now, when you say I'm scared to cover it,
what exactly would I say?
Because these are claims from two people.
They've not been verified by any independent
source and no evidence has been presented.
So given that there is no evidence, what exactly
could I say?
Now, the conspiracy theorists will say, Right,
but, David, they're hiding the evidence.
The fact remains, we have no evidence.
The claims of these two people in the last
couple of days have been contradicted by the
official report on unidentified aerial phenomena
that the Pentagon released in 2021.
Now, folks like this caller will say, but
that report is part of the effort to deceive
people and to hide the truth.
I don't have evidence of that.
And that sort of depends on whether you trust
these two people or whether you trust the
report that was published.
What do you prefer to rely upon?
Either way, I don't have evidence to support
what this caller is telling me.
So it's tough when people say you're not covering
it.
You should be covering it.
You're afraid to cover it.
What exactly could I add to the story?
There are unproven claims from one or maybe
two people for which no evidence has been
presented which some people see and say, That's
the cover up, that's the conspiracy.
I don't know what you want me to say about
it, because not only do I not have evidence
for the claims being made, I also don't have
evidence that there is any cover up taking
place.
And I know that.
B or C minded people say that's the evidence
of the conspiracy.
Absence of evidence is evidence, but that's
not really the type of show this is.
We have to deal in empiricism and reality
and evidence.
So I'm open to hearing from the audience.
Is this a story I should be aggressively covering?
Should I be all over the claims of one or
maybe two people that the US has intact alien
spacecraft, absent any evidence suggesting
that that's the case, or is there not very
much for me to say about it?
Let me know what you think and I will be guided
by the audience.
We are going to have such a great bonus show
for you today.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Yes.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad.
Speaker 1: Assisting us in making money.
On today's bonus show, we are going to talk
about another explosive Republican campaign
launched for president.
The governor of North Dakota, Doug Burgum,
is running.
I know, I know.
You've never heard of him, but he's running.
Okay.
We'll talk about it.
Number two, the group Moms for Liberty has
been designated an extremist group and Trump's
a big fan of the group.
We will talk about that.
And number three, by popular demand, we will
talk about the Apple Vision Pro.
This has been revealed by Apple.
I have many thoughts.
We will discuss them on the bonus show sign
up at join pacman dot com.
Don't miss today's bonus show produced every
single weekday for our members and you can
use the coupon code indicted very relevant
coupon code today to get a discount at join
packman dot com.
I'll see you then or will be back here tomorrow
for the Friday.